what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I do my
call I do my makeup and my hair
sometimes I drink coffee and I tell you
about my life
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
um I know a lot of you miss the curls
um in all honesty I don't know how to
curl my hair if anyone does it it's my
friend she'll come over here and do it
yeah unfortunately I am not that smart
when it comes to hair makeup
makeup I I need to get better though
because I am an entertainment so
whatever all right anyways so
the most common I think criticism I get
is that I'm either playing dumb I am
dumb and I have no real depth to my
opinions
so I want to tell you about the opinion
I don't feel bad for women and where
that opinion came from and why I think
that
so in in life and myself as a woman I've
made choices that have had certain
outcomes and every outcome that I've had
is my own own fault
and I have to say
that I've had a choice in that now as a
man
as a man
what choice do you have
now you either deal with women or you
don't deal with women those are your
only two choices to be safe
now I know what you're thinking well
just pick the right girl
I want to tell you about an interview I
did yesterday with this man
um that has been involved in the court
system in the UK
and he explained to me the system
that
they go through
here
oh my gosh why is someone's calling me
um
okay
so the first thing that women do when
they want to leave a marriage
as they go to a general practitioner a
teacher
and what they'll do there
is they might say oh
you've been abused okay
so then they're referred to a women's
Aid shelter and what happens at the
women's Aid shelter is they teach them
how to secure the children
and the finances and they have a whole
blueprint ready to go waiting
now I know what you're thinking
that can't be true well
if he's
of Indian descent India they don't
respect women there women don't have
rights and everything I had to do the
last 10 years was coercive control now
what is coercive control
it's damn near anything that is used to
control a woman which in a marriage I
mean on some level you are controlled I
mean you have to be
there's two people's minds in the
household you have to make decisions so
now the thing about the UK is that there
I'm here
you can call the police to get
um you only get
counsel if
which is like a lawyer for free
if you were abused so what do they do
they call the police
and in 2013 when they passed this there
was Aid federal aid for abuse abuse
cases
um went up by 200 percent
and I think the town was Coventry alone
okay
then then so they call the police now
mind you the women can do this with zero
evidence
so a man could just be living his life
having a good time
and what happens
before he knows it
he has a restraining order they call it
a non-molestation order here
and they can lock you up with zero
evidence
none
okay and typically you go to court and
the judge has to stamp it and typically
the judge just stamps it because when
there's a crying woman
I mean who doesn't who doesn't believe
that
okay
then
during this time he slapped with child
support So now
he can't see his kids because of the
restraining order on top of that he has
to pay
a bunch of money in child support
his wife left him
and he doesn't have any friends because
the entire Community thinks he's an
abuser now mind you in Family Court
you don't need any evidence to make any
of these claims
it's based on a balance of probability
so what happens next let's say he
doesn't pay the child support he could
either go to jail or
they just take it out of his bank
account
they just take it
now
and if he reaches out to his children
he can also
which he's legally allowed to do there
have been cases
of
the women saying that that's abuse as
well
and it just furthers the restraining
order now I could be butchering this a
little bit okay
but I I spoke to a man yesterday that
went through this so then
he has to wait for a court application
to see his kids now remember she took
his kids away with no evidence
and
this could take up six months to a year
to even get to court and with kovid some
men were not seeing their kids for two
years before they could even have a
chance to get their kids back now
imagine you have a newborn or
two-year-old
and you haven't seen those kids in two
years and you have two options okay you
go to court you can either take the
guilty plea or you can fight it now what
happens when you fight at one
your kids aren't even yours anymore
because it's been one to two years you
know maybe she has a new boyfriend
um and the mother's been in their ear
for two years I mean if it's a
four-year-old five-year-old a
six-year-old by the time you get the kid
back they might not even like you
anymore
because of what's been in their ear
now
so if you go the guilty plea then you're
a domestic abuse per you do the domestic
abuse perpetrator program your entire
life is destroyed you have to pay 2 000
a month or whatever
four or two thousand dollars for that
domestic abuse program
now
they could also
try to fight it
and the issue is when you fight it
the lawyers will charge you twenty to
forty thousand dollars now remember you
may have lost your job at this point
because
I mean you lost everything you lost your
house and remember you also have to pay
I forgot to put this in there for the
house that they're living in the deeds
in your name
everything's in your name you have so
you now have to pay for the expenses on
your old house
child support
and potentially the domestic abuse
perpetrator program or or
the lawyer which costs 20 to 40 thousand
dollars
two if you're lucky see your kids six
days a month now let's say you fight it
let's say you go to court you want to
see your kids you don't care you're
willing to go to the ends of the Earth
to see your children
well
what happens next
you win sort of well you don't get to
see them all the time but you get six
days a month and that's a win honestly
so when you get you get them on weekends
and half of holidays all right great
thank you
unless you're the primary custody owner
you're at her mercy because you could go
through this for two years and she could
just do it again
and remember when you do go to court
she's got the women's Aid helping her
and you're broke you have no money
and let's be honest guys most people
aren't in the red pill space so when
they see a woman crying they're gonna
automatically believe her
and in all honesty the lawyers don't
really have your best interest at heart
because
their number one client
is the women's groups what happens if
they start winning too many cases their
number one client
it's going to stop giving them cases
now
why don't we just change the laws
well
the number one swing voter is single
mothers
so
why would the politicians help you when
it's going to make them lose their job
so when I say that I don't feel bad for
women
now
everyone's going to come forward well
just don't just date a good woman well
the man I talked to yesterday is three
girls
and
he married a woman of a Muslim
background good family
and the issue you're going to get in
relationships is women lead and control
relationships because if two people are
in a deal and one person gains
everything by leaving and one person
loses everything by leaving
the person that loses everything is
always going to try harder to make it
work and be at the whim of this person
and you might think that your girl would
never do that to you
but
power does crazy things to people I mean
Julius Caesar got killed by his group of
friends
and
what choice did this man really have I
mean he did everything right now mind
you if you're in your 20s or 30s
you could rebuild you might be okay but
if you're in your 50s 60s 40s
you now have no money
monthly payments you can't afford you're
paying for your old house
your whole entire Community thinks
you're an abuser
foreign
you just spent twenty to forty thousand
dollars on
to get your kids back only to see them
six days a month if your baby mother
allows you to and your kids don't even
like you because she's been saying such
horrible things about you the last
couple of years
and this is a silent
a silent almost genocide that's going on
against men because
they're
and this is something that I started to
realize during this like red pill I
started asking my Uber drivers
have you ever had been involved in the
family court system
and I would say one to two of them had
I want to go down the street and
interview the homeless people I've never
had sympathy for homeless people ever
I've always felt like that is your own
fault I mean think about it
however
if I was in a situation where
my kids hated me the person I loved more
than anyone in the world anyone in the
world took everything from me
um
I worked for 20 years and to provide for
my family and as a thank you she took
the kids
and it's funny not funny it's actually
really sad
um but it's interesting that a lot of
times the women in court will come
forward and say oh he was never around
because he was working
I thought that was a good thing
so when guys say just marry the right
girl people do crazy things when they
have power
and the issue is that women
have so much power that is just
unchecked
and there's no incentive for anyone to
fix this problem is what I'm learning
because
why would you
the politicians will lose their jobs the
child support group will lose their
money the women's groups would go out of
business the lawyers would lose their
clients
um the police officers are at the will
of the government oh
so why would they fix it
there's no incentive for anyone to fix
this
so what do the men do they adapt they
say you know what I'm only dealing with
women casually because the laws are so
against me
um
which they're shamed for why are you
contributing to the problem they say you
know what
I'm not going to get legally married
women recreational use only and we shame
them
for going this route
when by going and the sad part is the
guy I talked to didn't even legally get
married he didn't he thought he avoided
the risk by not legally getting married
he just did the religious ceremony
when you have a kid it's not your kid
it's her kid
and that's the sad part of this whole
thing
and that's why I say I don't feel bad
for women
because
at the end of the day we always have a
choice we have the choice to get an
abortion
we have the choice to leave we have the
choice to screw him over to not screw
him over
the men are always at the will of the
women and this interacts the way that we
act in relationships
the men will then get Flack for not
leading not picking the right girl well
how can you shame a man for not leading
when the woman always can walk away
or the man
will always have the fear have more of a
fear of walking away than the woman
so he's going to work harder to appease
her which is you know kind of behavior
why do you think we have all these
phrases happy wife happy life because
men are in prison a lot of them
they're in these prisons where they
don't sleep with their wives
and if they leave they lose everything
enough to start over
and you know a lot of young guys will
criticize the older men for this
approach
because I don't think a lot of people
guys realize how bad it is
so
that's why I don't feel bad for women
that's why I have no sympathy that's why
when I go on shows with Destiny and he
says
oh well women have it hard too well you
know I I don't know if
women's heart of
because even if women have it hard okay
even if we get raped or something bad
happens we can at least pursue it to the
fullest extent of the law
if a woman
takes everything and his kids there's no
consequence none
so you can't tell me that women have it
harder you can't tell me but women
because at the end of the day
the men have to go through this
and the women will always have systems
to back them if I get abused if I get
graped if anything happens to me I can
go to the law and pursue it to the
fullest extent of the law
and if there is evidence there will be a
conviction now
You could argue with no evidence nothing
will happen
but there are so many resources that we
have
where the men are just screwed every day
and I think it's an epidemic and I think
it's going on below our noses I think
it's way more common than we think
and that's my next series I'm really
going to investigate is how how big is
this problem
because they always say it won't happen
to you just pick the right girl
but if that was me the more I learned
about this [__] I'm terrified four men
I mean I'm a woman so I'm okay but it's
like
if if that was me I wouldn't deal with
women either
so
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time